[Música]
cuando yo era niño en la década de los
80 la tecnología era muy limitada no
estaba masificada apenas empezamos a ver
la televisión a color es mi padre un
ingeniero inglés se las ingenió para
lograr captar a través de un transmisor
radial las señales de radio en distintas
partes del mundo
y para mí eso era fascinante
indescriptible el hecho de poder oír a
los locutores en inglés alemán francés u
otro idioma a tiempo real
imaginación volaba tratando de descifrar
cómo vivían en otras partes del mundo
pasaron los años las décadas pasamos de
siglo y hoy vivimos una revolución
tecnológica digital que se acelera día a
día la tecnología nos transforma
internet nos ha permitido acortar
distancias estar conectados con el mundo
entero si así lo deseamos vivimos una
revolución digital que avanza a pasos
agigantados no estás sumergido en un
terreno dotado de nuevos dispositivos
equipos y herramientas digitales que
influyen directamente en nuestro
comportamiento como seres humanos como
miembros de una familia y una sociedad e
influyen también en nuestras libertades
y esto a su vez incide directamente en
la democracia porque somos nosotros los
ciudadanos los que vamos a determinar el
tipo de democracia que queremos
construir o mantener sin embargo habrán
notado que a lo largo de los siglos la s
de los principios y valores de la
democracia se han mantenido inalterable
pensemos en los principios de libertad
igualdad y fraternidad de la revolución
francesa o los pilares en los que recae
la democracia liberal de occidente
sustentado en los derechos civiles y
políticos en el parlamento y jueces
independientes la democracia es el
gobierno del pueblo y esa esencia se
mantiene pero las fuerzas externas
propias de la era digital actual han
propiciado una transformación que va
arremetiendo en los cimientos de la
democracia que se concibe desde la
participación ciudadana porque la
democracia también implica una forma de
vida de interacción entre personas con
reglas y normas que velan por el buen
funcionamiento de la sociedad es una
convivencia humana entre tú y yo entre
todos nosotros y hoy a través de
internet y las redes sociales
interactuamos de otra manera damos vida
a nuevas iniciativas y movimientos que
se gestan online y luego se trasladan al
plan offline o mejor dicho a las calles
oa la vida real en busca de lograr un
cambio o un objetivo
y uno participaba una marcha pacífica en
los últimos tiempos y así y muchísimas
veces entonces la democracia per se no
varía la esencia es la misma pero las
formas como ejercemos esa nueva
ciudadanía de la mano y la tecnología
serán decisivas para la nueva democracia
que está surgiendo y que cada vez cobra
más fuerza es una transformación en
donde todos somos cómplices ciudadanos y
ciudadanía todos estos años que llevo
promoviendo la democracia digital en
nuestros países me ha permitido darme
cuenta y constatar como una ciudadanía
empoderada a través de la tecnología es
capaz de emprender de desarrollar
proyectos de ayudar a otros de impulsar
transformaciones que va desde el plano
personal hasta pequeñas revoluciones en
su comunidad su región o país es esa
transformación ciudadana a través de la
tecnología lo que impacta en la
democracia
hoy en día todos llevamos un arma somos
un ejército cívico que incluye cada vez
a más personas con esta arma podemos
proteger pero también podemos hacer daño
un auto nos sirve para desplazarnos pero
también podríamos usarlo para atropellar
a personas un cuchillo sirve para cortar
los alimentos pero también puede quitar
vidas acá el asunto crucial es el uso
que nosotros le otorgamos a ese
instrumento es decir para hacer el bien
o el mal la intención detrás es decisiva
internet fue creado para servir a la
humanidad primero con fines específicos
a nivel científico académico y militar y
luego masificándose ampliamente para que
más personas se vean favorecidas lo
cierto es que todas esas bondades y
beneficios que nos ofreció internet
desde un primer momento de pronto fueron
postergados por aquellos elementos
negativos que empezaron a surgir en la
red que repito no fue la herramienta por
sí misma sino el uso que nosotros le
damos recordemos la primavera árabe en
el año 2010
les cuento cuando nuestro programa
democracia digital surgió en el perú fue
a raíz de otra serie de movilizaciones
que se daban simultáneamente en el año
2013 y que tenían como común denominador
el uso de las tecnologías digitales para
canalizar el sentimiento hacerte visible
o buscar apoyo exterior justamente en el
celular esa arma que todos llevaban para
denunciar al mundo lo que vivía en los
últimos días el hashtag ese o ese cuba
fue el más compartido desde los móviles
en la isla con fotos y vídeos reportando
lo que ahí sucedía es que internet tiene
un efecto poderoso que nos permite alzar
las voces democratizar la información
acceder a información pública deliberar
libremente empoderar e incluir a los
ciudadanos fomentar la creación de
emprendimientos
cómo sientes que te ayuda a internet una
columnista de una influyente revista
norteamericana sostenía internet ha
permitido que una mujer negra y lesbiana
como yo puede expresarse y dar a conocer
su voz en serio piensa cómo sientes que
te ayuda a internet sin embargo todo
esto positivo hoy se siente amenazado
por la desinformación y las noticias
falsas que circulan en la red los
discursos de odio el acoso digital el
bloqueo y la censura online la
vigilancia los delitos cibernéticos
recién vimos también en cual los
apagones de internet para silenciar a
esa población disidente y disuadir a los
movimientos sociales prácticas
recurrentes en regímenes totalitarios en
el año 2008 el ex presidente barack
obama fue el pionero en realizar una
campaña política bajo una estrategia
digital emblemática donde supo
aprovechar muy bien los espacios
digitales para captar votantes creado
crear una red de voluntarios y recibir
donaciones a la campaña el mundo entero
aplaude
y el poder de las redes tras su triunfo
ocho años después vivimos una
experiencia distinta el ex presidente de
donald trump también haría uso excesivo
de las redes sociales durante su campaña
muchos incluso la consideraron una
twittera lesión sin embargo a partir de
entonces se empezó a percibir ese uso
perverso de una red que podría ser
fácilmente manipulada para manipular
valga la redundancia a los usuarios
digitales a fin de lograr un propósito
desde entonces el escenario online
cambió y no sólo para la política lo
hemos visto en procesos democráticos
importantes en distintas latitudes del
mundo también en tiempos recientes
durante la pandemia por kobe 19 en medio
del aislamiento y el dolor por la
enfermedad o pérdida a nuestros amigos y
familiares internet se convirtió en el
mejor salvavidas para poder continuar
con nuestras vidas cotidianas con la
educación el trabajo el comercio y las
actividades de todo tipo no obstante a
pesar de su gran aporte al mismo tiempo
otro gran virus se propagaba
esta es información online sin
precedentes una desinformación que
aprovechaba el escenario de
incertidumbre y miedo para afectar la
salud y la seguridad de las personas
mientras buscábamos cómo protegernos
también se realizaban teorías de
conspiración sobre el virus las
mascarillas y las vacunas acentuando la
desconfianza y el daño creo que todos lo
hemos vivido verdad internet mostraba
ser una arma de doble filo por el uso o
mal uso que nosotros los ciudadanos le
dimos y esto será determinante para el
tipo de democracia que queremos
hace nueve años cuando empecé este
hermoso trabajo vinculado a la
democracia digital me topé con muchísima
gente escéptica oí decir las cosas más
tremendas pues bajo sus ojos no sé
estaban preparados para vivir en un
mundo digital pasar del mundo analógico
al digital significaba para muchos
entrar en crisis lo cierto es que la
tecnología llegó para quedarse
debemos entenderlo así y lo más
importante es aceptar que esta
tecnología inevitablemente está
transformando la manera como
tradicionalmente hemos funcionado como
seres humanos como ciudadanos en
sociedad y en democracia además hay que
tener en cuenta algo muy importante no
sabemos cómo vendrá la tecnología mañana
pues cambia de manera permanente y nos
sorprende día a día pero si sabemos y
conocemos de la democracia de sus
principios y pilares desconocemos el
futuro tecnológico pero conocemos muy
bien la esencia de la democracia
dependerá de nosotros darle forma a esa
democracia que adopta los matices
la nueva ciudadanía producto de la
revolución digital somos los ciudadanos
los que vamos a tallar el nuevo molde
del modelo democrático contemporáneo y
también futuro y nuestra misión debiera
ser como empleamos internet en las
distintas soluciones online para lograr
una democracia plena inclusiva
participativa deliberativa una
democracia que integre a través de la
tecnología a todos y todas y nadie quede
excluido retrocedo a mi niñez y recuerdo
a ese transmisor radial de mi padre que
transformaba mi imaginación ahora me doy
cuenta que es el poder de la tecnología
lo que nos transforma despertando
nuestras emociones y sentimientos y nos
abre paso a la creación recae en
nosotros crear uno mejor reflexionemos
como usamos esta tecnología para nuestra
convivencia democrática que molde
estamos callando difundimos información
sin verificar contribuimos al acoso
digital escondemos nuestra identidad en
las redes pensemos por qué esas pequeñas
acciones pueden hacer la diferencia cada
uno de nosotros decide todos los días si
queremos ser troll ers influencers
consumidores o más bien ciudadanos
responsables en esta nueva democracia
digital
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah